there are very few things Batman doesn't
excel at and even fewer that he just
can't do it all they do exist however
and there's one character who can do
quite a bit that Batman can't the Joker
here are the things that the Joker can
do that Batman just can't while there
have been plenty of stories over the
years where the Dark Knight employs
lethal methods and his fight against
crime
the idea that Batman doesn't kill people
has been a pretty solid general rule in
comics since 1941 you won't kill me out
of some misplaced sense of
self-righteousness not coincidentally
that's about as long as the Joker's been
murdering people by the dozens in Batman
number one the comic that contains the
Joker's first appearance the Clown
Prince of Crime manages to murder no
fewer than 12 people through a
combination of poison and good
old-fashioned handguns that pretty much
set the tone for the next 75 years and
even though he spent a few years focused
more on bank robberies and gimmick
crimes he's more than made up for it in
the year since with an unofficial count
by fans putting his body count at over
540 on panel deaths it's not just
quantity either with high-profile deaths
like Jason Todd the second Robin and
Sarah Essen
Jim Gordon's second wife with all those
twos you think Harvey Dent was the one
responsible there's no other Gotham City
villain with a body count that even
comes close and the only villains in the
entire DC Universe who can beat it
are the cosmic threats who have wiped
out entire parallel universes even if
Batman was a killer it's hard to believe
he'd go that far with all the childhood
trauma self sacrifice and violent
confrontations Batman's brain probably
isn't exactly a pleasant place for a
mind reader to be still he's never
driven someone insane just by giving
them a peek inside his psyche we know
someone who has though
hi
on multiple occasions the martian
manhunter you know the guy with all of
Superman's powers plus he can turn
invisible and read your mind has been
confronted with Joker's brain it did not
go well he could barely keep himself
saying while poking around up there
considering he can keep the entire
Justice League telepathically linked at
once the fact that Joker's brain alone
was so harrowing should tell you just
how much his mind affects anyone who
takes a peek
crime never takes a vacation which means
that Batman doesn't either he's so
dedicated that he rarely takes a rest
even when he needs it super criminals on
the other hand are free to take as many
breaks as they want assuming they're not
busy paying their debt to society in an
asylum that seems to be held together
with spit and chicken wire there's
always somebody like the flu master or
the electrocutioner waiting around to
take their shot so why not in fact we
actually know that in the comics canon
the Joker always makes sure to take a
vacation once a year the catch according
to Aztec the ultimate man number 6 he
only goes somewhere worse than Gotham
given the state of the DC Universe in
the late 90s when Gotham was afflicted
with two plagues and an earthquake on
top of all the other regular
supervillain attacks that meant going to
some pretty bad places and when the
Joker takes these little trips Batman
sees it as his responsibility to bring
him back to justice meaning that
whenever the Joker takes a vacation
Batman by definition has to work say
what you will about the Joker but at
least he keeps his sidekicks alive what
too soon look we hate to say it but
Batman doesn't have a spotless track
record when it comes to his sidekicks
Jason Todd had his brains bashed in the
spoiler was tortured to death with a
power drill by Black Mask Bruce Wayne's
bodyguard Sasha Bordeaux was shanked in
prison after being framed as an
accessory to murder even his own son
Damian died which wound up driving
Batman so crazy that he tracked down
Frankenstein to figure out how to bring
corpses back to life sure all four of
those people came back to life
eventually but they still went through
some rough stuff
but the Joker believe it or not
batting a thousand Harlequin is not only
alive she's also become one of DC's most
popular and marketable characters over
the past couple decades with multiple
starring roles and comics that have
lasted longer than the Joker's ever did
heck even gaggy gags worthy a sidekick
who appeared in a single issue back in
the 60s is still alive somewhere out
there in the multiverse he was in comics
as recently as 2009
Batman couldn't keep Robin alive but the
Joker managed to keep gaggy around for
40 years of course once in a while the
Joker remembers to be the Joker here's
one thing you can't take away from
Batman he's massively popular he has
been since the start propelling
Detective Comics to such Heights that
it's publisher would eventually rename
their entire company DC after it he
starred in thousands of comics a whole
bunch of movies cartoons that have been
more or less constant since 1992 and
even had his own breakfast cereal the
Joker of course is also popular arguably
the single most popular villain in the
history of superhero comics but while
Detective has passed 1000 plus over 800
issues of Batman and not to mention all
those other bat-sensor titles the Joker
managed to get his only solo series
cancelled after just nine issues of
course that was back in 1975 with a
pretty different version of the
character than we have today it also
just wasn't that good probably because
it's kind of difficult to get behind a
remorseless homicidal maniac as a
protagonist of course it didn't help
that Batman never appeared in it leading
the Joker to fight some random dude who
got hit in the head and thought he was
Sherlock Holmes but the Joker is a proud
clown it has to sting a little bit that
his only solo outing couldn't even break
double digits check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]